you've got a H what you say in a civic
sense of humor
oh I don't know you could be tough like
for example what do you call your wife
and kids in this book I call them the
lady that I'm married boy number one and
the other one which no yes you ever
worry that you say things about your
kids and I know you're just kidding but
you ever worry they're gonna get mad
later on as they grow into adulthood
look I have made enough money that they
will have great counsellors and pretty
sweet cars to drive and if they her
complain about it I'll be like here's a
bag of money go no I don't they my
children don't really take me seriously
anyway right like my son Isaac if
someone walks up to me and says hey
emaciated Conan O'Brien no kidding they
would never say wow you guys really are
on Conan side they're on my side they're
on my side they're here to see Conan's
I will I will play the room differently
dummy no uh oh no that's a worse way to
go the other secret is they like Andy
more
that's how people love dumb animals
ya know but my my my 8 year old if
someone walks up to me and says like I
like your show can I have a picture and
then I'll do that and then they'll walk
away and then my 8 year old will go oh
is that your fan today do they like what
you do do they like your work do they
like you for the perfect way for your
son to be that is perfect I have no
comeback other than push them off the
sidewalk yeah
you